well I'd like to say my own version of
the classic formulation which is inform
and entertain the way I often put it is
I like to tell good stories and ask big
questions and biography is a way of it's
sending a message to the reader that
you're telling a story you have a
narrative arc it's about a human being
and it's a story with a beginning middle
and an end at the same time biography
allows me to explore big questions about
the making of modern America so for
example when I look at somebody like
Jesse James or Keneally's Vanderbilt
these are people had very dramatic lives
and had they're also iconic figures so
there will recognize and they speak to
something about the way Americans think
about themselves but who we are as a
people in the way even more important
we've argued about who we are so you
know there are these tremendously
exciting and dramatic and interesting
stories within their lives and at the
same time they're about something big
and they touch on big themes and so
that's the what draws me to those those
sorts of people in those subjects
and when I write a biography I both
respect that that barrier that I cannot
penetrate and yet at the same time I'm
constantly concerned with what is on the
other side of that barrier and and
trying to point to what lies beneath
even when I can't take the reader there
and this is a very delicate aspect of
biography you can't make stuff up you
can't go too far in drawing conclusions
sometimes the very limitations of the
evidence is the story or the the fact
that you can't quite figure something
out itself is a part of the story so you
can't resurrect the dead ultimately you
can't get into their inner lives and yet
at the same time we're constantly
striving for it or trying to point to
this untouchable aspect of someone's
life and to provoke thoughts about it in
the reader